one day the first coach of the first
team he went out and he saw me in a game
and he was like I wanna have a meeting
with you and I was like okay what did I
do know as a kid you never know what you
will become because you have a lot of
dreams from I wanted to be a lawyer is
not a joke I'm a family guy I'm I'm
taking care of my family but when I come
on the pitch I'm a lion I think my time
is passed for going to England but then
you never know what happens in football
if I'm not a gristick I will be a simple
player and I don't see myself as a
simple pair
he's a Swedish professional football
player who plays the striker position
with Manchester United he's widely
regarded as one of the best strikers in
the game and one of the best footballers
of his generation he's Latin ibrahimovic
and here's my take on his top ten rules
for success rule number four is my
personal favorite and make sure to
sticker on all the way to the end for
some special bonus clubs before 17 I was
like the last one to they consider to
become good I mean one day the first
coach of the first team he went out and
he saw me in a game and he was like I
wanna have a meeting with you and I was
like okay what did i do no I mean every
time I had a meeting was for some kind
of disciplinary thing and and then he
said on Monday you start to train with
the big guys you're in a first team and
then I was like from considering to be
they're not the biggest talent like
let's say the last one in the group to
jump over all of them and come in the
first group and I was okay and I was in
shock because and I didn't want to say
it too much because maybe if I talk too
much he will change his mind
I was like ok see you on Monday then
when they saw me they saw the player
that was different from the other ones
it was a great feeling but at the same
time I was like now I have opportunity
to do something good out of it and it's
pretty it's up to me so if I want to to
become something that I think I can
become I have to train hard and that's
my mentality I like to train hard I mean
you can have talent but talent don't
take you all the way I had a lot of
dreams
as a kid you never know what you will
become because you have a lot of dreams
from I wanted to be a lawyer is not a
joke but I became a football player so
that was one of the dreams and when I
look looked at TV I thought said yeah
for example I saw the big players and I
say if they can do it I can do it and
that's the mentality if somebody else
can do it you can do it and I said to
myself I will do it and I will do it
better that's the mentality and I
believe with the mentality is 50% of the
success in what you're doing
what's so personally I'm a normal person
I mean people have the image of me that
I'm a I'm a bad boy I'm this I'm dead
people are curious how is this Latin and
that I'm a family guy I'm I'm taking
care of my family but when I come on the
pitch I'm a lion that's the big
difference so you can separate the two
but you're you're well aware of the
image of you and as you know the word
that crops up the most is arrogant but
do you think that's getting less and
less I don't believe that a American in
the way that people think I'm confident
I have a big coffee
I believe in myself that's that's not
being arrogant that's something that I
believe is like it's a individual
strength in the in the human being I
have confidence I believe in myself and
I have a vision and and I do everything
and I work hard for it and I don't
believe that surrogate this time was
nice I mean I get a longbow from my Khan
I thought was too high and I saw
Stankiewicz going and the only way I
could put it in front was like this
jumping up and put it back were you
afraid of falling
no absolutely not I was under present
convinced that I will give it good to
him I need became good to do things you
have to believe in it if you don't
believe if you think you will fall down
break your leg then don't do it when I
was young I had a lot of people telling
me you have to adjust to the other ones
you have to be like the other ones
I was listening but I wasn't always
following I dragged it in how do you say
I was listening but I did my own thing I
kept doing my own thing and I believed
in myself what was like the question
there like they judge you even before
you come and they don't even know you
and that was outside the pitch and
inside the pitch but I kept going I kept
going and it brought me where I am today
confidence and believing what you do
that is I think that is the gold target
is there a time in the future where you
could end up in England I don't know I
mean in football you never know I always
said it but I really enjoy France now
this project with PSG is really
triggering me it's really amazing that
is developing very fast
they have many champions there today and
still they want to become what they said
from all the beginning like they wanna
make dream to come true and and I really
enjoy I'm very happy there and they if
I'm saying opposite I'm lying so to come
to England I think my time is passed for
going to England but then you never know
what happens in football because when I
came to Barcelona I was living in my
dream and in my head I was there five
years but at the end I was there one
year so every time I plan my future I
change it so better to take one day one
day at time
PSG dominating in France you were loads
of goals a wall
trophies do you think you needed a new
challenge let's say I will never turn
down a challenge so when these challenge
came when it was presented to me I would
never turn down I'm not like many others
where they sit good they have it good
and they know they can perform at top
and they would never change but me I'm
opposite I will take the challenge and I
will and I'll go for it I will work hard
I will sacrifice and then what outcome
becomes will have to wait and see but
turn down a challenge it doesn't exist
in my world I've been in every country
with England now and and that is what I
find that venture cooled because I came
my one and I went so hopefully I can do
the same here every challenge I take I
have a big vision I put a lot of effort
a lot of sacrificing things I do it if I
don't do it it means I don't believe in
it in this I believe very strong and I
will not give up until I'm top of the
world so that's the way it works you aim
for the top
you don't aim for the second second
place is the first place among the last
ones and that's not my target I think
every player has to be egoistic that is
also a quality that is a very big
important important see in football
because I mean I'm on the field I have
to do my things I have to score my goals
I have to create the chances to score to
do that you have to be a little bit
acoustic because egg ristic is also a
quality if I'm not a gristick I will be
a simple player and I don't see myself
as a simple pair
you have many simple players but you
have few who makes the difference you
make the difference I'm trying
follow me follow me nobody talks let us
let it up why not
even followed budget TV you want to
speak this pickle jar yeah
how are you doing purpose yeah I'm okay
yeah you're even more ugly in television
and they even could make a certain image
of mine with one less and even went in
the extra time but they should have all
the credit they can get and I mean if
they would because it's not easy to
everything guys especially I guess the
thing like Chelsea
ensure quality and big
I don't know
have to get angry or
but
for me there
when I saw the red card I was like
doesn't all of these what he's doing or
maybe he saw something else
the world the versus when I see when I
get the Red Hat all the Chelsea players
come around
that for me I don't know
felt like a the living babies around
I pulled up I pulled up because I saw
him also coming the tackle and I pulled
out
I don't know if he was acting afterwards
or
you feel better now since two months
yeah
in champion you choking in a little
chicken chicken big one something tell
ya
if you don't know for your information
on other is one how you doing man
is it hard watching the World Cup not
being a
what do you think of Landon Donovan not
playing for the Landon Donovan it's his
problem it's his problem who do you
think is gonna win like in your mind you
assist you are you kidding me is that a
joke the big show oh and this dear girl
television yes you know a caller questo
be short-sighted Emma
Cinco - cool okay
no we fini no no no we we also talita
telling in Brno South Africa
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Lata bo M asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
in the comments below and I'll see what
I can do
I'd also love to know which of the top
ten rolls had the biggest impact on you
and why what change you're going to make
in your business or personal life as a
result of watching this video leave in
the comments and I will join in the
discussion finally want to give a quick
shout out to Ismael Ismael thank you so
much for buying my book it really means
a lot to me for your chance at a shadow
in a future video make sure to pick up a
copy of the book and email in your
receipt so we can keep track thank you
guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
who were your idols when you were young
and have they changed since my big Idol
past a couple of days ago it was
Muhammad Ali for me he was a big
inspiration he was my idol this was one
of my dreams to meet him but it will not
happen but what he did for in the ring
outside ring
nobody will reach halfway of what he did
he put it color not for one country put
it color for the whole world and what he
stood for so he's a big inspiration to
take after him I had a dream to come to
Barcelona but afterwards I'm thinking
maybe you should keep your dream instead
of making it come through because that
dream could almost not almost could have
not destroy me but make it difficult for
me and first six months fantastic I had
a fantastic time I had a very good
relationship with Guardiola I wanted to
learn the Barcelona the way of playing
it went good for six months after that
something happened that I still don't
have answers for which which maybe I
will never know I mean if somebody has a
problem with me should come to me we
resolve it whatever the problem is like
a man because was it was ridiculous you
don't talk to the player the player is
looking for answers at that moment I was
not happy and I said I have to choose
either I stay win everything but I will
not be happy or I go to somewhere else
and that is what that I went to Milan my
joy kept back for playing football did a
good job
I wonder the Scudetto immediately among
the supercoppa everybody was happy and
they were like appreciating me for
playing there a lot of stuff you say you
say with a big smile on your face and
tongue in cheek you play up to this
image so you deserve some of it you have
fun with it don't you I have a lot of
fun with it absolutely I'm just being
myself I'm not pretending to be somebody
I'm not I'm not pretending to be perfect
I'll do mistakes I did mistakes I
learned from it but I will still repeat
my
mistakes that as the human human life
everybody does the same thing and the
one who think is the most perfect guy he
will he will fall and he will fall very
fast so alone so a lot of people need to
are scolding him off
I'll get you moved up don't worry your
questions is too easy you need to bring
up the heat so come on admit a lot of it
is an act dare to slattern this stuff is
just you having fun I don't believe in
acting because I don't get paid to get
it to act be myself so I'm always myself
from the first day so I don't pretend
nothing I'm just myself and I do people
like it or they don't like it I don't
care because I'm not here to to make up
I acting part I'm here to play football
I'm here to to win and in the end of the
career or when you stop playing football
people remember you for what you want